what's your long-term game meaning do
you guys have any plans of one day
getting married having a family having
kids oh no
okay so there we go so not at all
well
you know you could hit it first so we
have different different views on yes so
honestly speaking um in the west uh in
our opinion marriage for men there's no
benefit at all they mean it for women
and as a result um most guys they come
into it blindly hey this girl loves me
likes me for me wink wink
and you know they get into marriage with
this woman and before you know it she's
leaving because her emotions taking half
of whatever you own and you're back to
scoring one or even worse so in our
opinion regarding marriage like
you have to know what you get into first
and be aware of all the laws
from against men because
if you look at it from a legal
standpoint like a logical standpoint
regarding the actual contract of
marriage it's like a contract that says
hey you know what at any point in time
the woman says i don't feel like anymore
she just leave take half your stuff and
as a result men are like either left uh
to the whim of you know women or for
example the mercy of them so we just say
hey you know what if you're gonna do it
probably do it without the state maybe
in church or outside the us because the
laws are not made for men to actually
win and i did it before in the past so
i'm actually married
when i first came to the states and
the whole experience man i'm not gonna
hold you it was it was good but also i
understood that hey you know what right
now my life is not for me and i had to
go could change so it could change one
day meaning one day we can wake up and
we got a podcast from fresh about how to
keep your marriage together
i'll say this
i'm open to change however yeah if i do
get married again it's probably gonna be
colombia
because i'm probably
colombia would you come here and i'll
come back okay so you would get married
i'll leave her over there in the
paperwork in colombia the regulations of
colombia yes and why is that because the
laws
what's the laws in colombia it's lacks i
don't know about child support i'd have
to worry about being um divorced great
because at that point
i'm not gonna be held under the u.s
standards and your standards are not
made out for men so it was great to not
use our word which is great are you more
concerned about the legal ramifications
of getting married or actually the
institution of marriage one woman or is
it a combination of both it's both i'll
say this let's be real here though in
the west there's not a lot of quality uh
leads you would say to uh want to marry
yeah really really in all of the west
what do you mean in america and in the
western hemisphere
quality women you can find good women
however the likelihood is very slim for
you nowadays social media what's going
on you know the feminist movement is
like bro they're americanized yeah
exactly but first of all
you're in line though the the feminist
movement i agree but you know there's a
big push for that about being equals i
mean if somebody said something david
right now said something interesting
about this whole story with the girl who
tried to the guy who was ranked 456 for
men
and goes and becomes a woman you know
apparently transgender is ranked first
and then he says that's another perfect
sign that you know no matter women try
to be men they can't beat them but if
men try to be a woman they beat them at
their own game so that's that's what
david said that's david's comments right
there
yeah but the point is do you have a
point about what direction it's going
and
it is a bit of the current society is
also probably discouraging younger men
of getting married because there's a lot
of fears and concerns you want me to go
build up my own well to eventually have
somebody take it away from me that's a
risk but also at the same time i can
address on that part is you know you can
you can have a job you can be a 1099
realtor
and a lot of guys just want to be
one-man shows you can go be a realtor
and you just sell homes right i don't
want to have i don't want to start a
real estate company with another guy
because i've heard a lot of horrible
stories if you start a realistic company
with another guy one guy leaves takes
after and done something
that risk is in business that risk isn't
marriage that risk is in every single
thing you ever do so you're right the
risk is there 100 but there's also very
good lawyers if you have money to have
the right kind of prenuptial agreements
which i'm fully forward if you got the
right lures how about yourself yeah so
uh my take on it is i definitely so we
believe in nuclear families and
institution of marriage like we think
it's a fantastic institution to be
honest with you to raise children in the
best light you need nuclear families
that is what that is the backbone of any
strong nation that's how the united
states was built that is how uh
superpowers were built was on the backs
of nuclear families right we know the
statistically speaking two-parent house
superior yep for child rearing right
however since we even though we know
that marriage is a great institution for
raising children everything we just
don't agree with the way that is done in
the west in general the laws have not
caught up to feminism it has not caught
up to women making their own money is
not caught up to all the the social
climate that we have now right so we
know you know about half of marriages
end in divorce we know 70 to 80 of those
marriages are divorces are initiated by
women and we know that about 90 percent
of harmony is paid for men to women so
knowing these numbers we tell guys if
you're gonna get married you need to get
married in a way where you can kind of
come in from a defensive standpoint to
protect what you have because
quite honestly when you get into a
marriage you're signing a contract with
someone that is incentivized to break it
and they will be rewarded for it which
is dangerous right to get in under that
premise so our thing is if you can get
married and not have the state be
involved that's the best way to do it so
like we understand the importance of it
but we also acknowledge that hey there's
a lot of dangerous situations here that
can really mess you up from a financial
standpoint if marriage doesn't work and
it's a very uh it's a crazy risk and you
know if someone's willing to take it i
just want them to go in knowing what's
going to happen if things don't work out
and put yourself in a position like you
said have the lawyers go talk to a
family attorney before you you know
think even think about walking down now
with a woman get a good strong
pronunciation agreement in place where
you can have it um updated every couple
years etc so if a guy takes these
precautions and then somehow finds a way
whether he's going to colombia going to
dominican republic whatever it may be
getting married where the state is not
involved in your affair so the woman
isn't incentivized to break up with you
and destroy you financially and or take
the kids and use this as some kind of
like leverage point i'm off for that
because families are needed you know
that's for sure that's a good argument
again i don't see a challenge with that
argument because
if you're getting married
and most people who get married they
believe in some kind of a higher power
denomination whether they're jews
catholics christian muslim it doesn't
matter so you want to get married by the
church so why do i need the federal
government to say that i'm married the
only benefit would be what tax benefits
is what you get which is some benefits
that you get it's not a lot of tax
benefits that you get yeah so maybe is
that it is that the only benefit of
getting but you have to tax deduction
the the argument of by the government is
a very good argument so if i'm getting
married by the church that's why i'm
getting married why do i need to get
married according to the government's
laws yeah because you're going to lock
me up i also understand that part as
well that argument but but let's go a
little bit deeper okay so and i will say
this real quick too just to finish up um
and the reason why i say you need to be
in this defensive position when you get
into you thinking about marriage or any
type of serious relationship with a
woman is because women here's a problem
and this is where i guess we can get a
little bit controversial women want
traditional men but they themselves are
not traditional so what we're saying is
that you're basically a lot of the times
what guys do is like they get into a
relationship with a girl they might not
necessarily understand intersexual
dynamics they don't understand how women
think and operate especially in today's
day and age where women are more
experienced sexually than ever before
and they get into relationship thinking
it's going to be a disney fairy tale and
next thing they know you know the world
flips upside down because they don't
understand how women move today things
have changed significantly you know
women are no longer traditional however
a lot of guys come into relationship
thinking i'm going to be traditional i'm
going to be this guy i'm going to be the
nice guy i'm going to be chivalrous a
gentleman or whatever and that just
doesn't work anymore women have changed
significantly right they've been
liberated they're you know they make
more money than ever made before a lot
of women in general that we've from what
we've seen in our interviews a lot of
women don't respect most men you know
most girls look at the average guy be
like 50 k per year five foot eight not
good enough for me you know a lot of
girls overestimate their their sexual
market values i was to say as far as
like what they think they deserve when
it comes to men and and we've asked
girls right we've even done polls what
do you consider yourself one out of ten
bro if i had a dollar for every time a
girl said 11 i'd be a billionaire at
this point you know what i'm saying it's
like
like um girls tend to grossly over value
themselves and you know there's a bunch
of we have a bunch of theories as to why
that is but um it's just not a good
market marriage market for most guys in
today's day and age in the west so they
need to get going with their eyes wide
open and come in from a position of
defense to protect their assets if they
are going to get involved in a marriage
because a lot of girls are not
traditional anymore if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]